I made an Appalachia I'm here to answer
the internet if you make any two people
fight in a no rules cage match who would
you choose Kamala and Hillary Clinton
who do you think wins that fight Kamala
I don't know I kind of think Hillary is
I think you get Hillary in the right
frame of mind and she takes out the last
40 Years of frustration out on someone
and she'll like rip someone to shreds
yeah I did meet him and her and she is
not nice
so maybe her [__]
she's kind of nasty what
uh in Mount Kisco I was at a restaurant
they were there yeah I asked to take a
picture with them they did but he wanted
to like take a selfie with me and then
she was like no
no
more pictures
no more [__]
the first thousand girls suck you up I
draw the line here well it's like it's a
little late in the game
right before the pandemic wow
dude they might murder you they might
then my special will blow up if you were
taking hostage five years ago what would
most surprise you wait what what
surprised you most about the world today
um
2018. I guess that we have a white
president
I would have thought we would have you
know Asian Puerto Rican transgender I
didn't think we'd go right back to White
I thought it kept going
I think it did pretty much go well okay
what else do we got
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blonde child who has the greatest
voice of our generation are you killing
the kid absolutely I don't even like
kids I don't care how would you kill
them
um probably bathtub I think that's the
way most people kill kids
let's watch them struggle for those last
couple seconds put all their toys around
isn't that how you'd want to be killed
in everything you love
would you rather orgasm every time you
hear All-Star by Smash Mouth or here all
star every time you're orgasm I guess uh
All-Star every time I orgasm so I would
definitely not hear it a lot
would you rather your mom or daughter be
a porn star my mom so that we would have
had money
and I wouldn't have to live in the Bronx
worse if you're a guy probably a
daughter as a daughter you care if your
mom is like the [__] no because I want
my boyfriend to be like do it like your
mom
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
Aliens who would it be Kanye West yes
I hope he wins president people always
think about that question as like like
who wants to welcome the aliens I want
who wants to scare them back but they're
like we're out of here we're out of here
crazy would you put your kid in a
gorilla pit for 50 Grand absolutely
I was willing to kill that other one for
nothing
sure
he's got a [__] yeah there's a chance
he'll make it out
would you rather suck one dick for 50
Grand or get a thousand dollars for
every dick you suck 50 great I would
rather suck one dick for 50 Grand really
a thousand a dick is like a money tree
I know but then you're just constantly
sucking dicks whatever you need a
thousand bucks
I mean you can make infinite money all
right I guess you all right you guys I
guess I was going by the guys dicks I
have sucked but you're saying it's
infinite I could just keep sucking yes
okay so yeah I would do that yeah what
about if it's like whatever dick comes
through the door though you get to go to
the room and be like I need a thousand
do you have to make it come yeah yeah
yeah yeah
can I wash it can I wash it first yeah
yeah
I didn't think that comes that's fine
because mine was like a wash what would
you trade a three-year-old baby for
a two-year-old baby
whenever they're gonna pay me on
Craigslist
how much do you think you get for a
white baby on Craigslist
um you can get a lot for a white baby I
just looking on Craigslist okay you got
to go to like the special black market
like I don't know how you do it yeah but
you find the black market people buying
babies a white baby's gonna be through
the roof if you're on Craigslist you're
gonna get Craigslist people who have
like I'll give you 2500 for that okay so
I'd have to find the right people just
sex trafficking to find like Bridge
people do it on there or sex traffickers
yeah that might be better I think that's
better because three is a little young
I don't want to raise it yeah exactly I
think I'm gonna go with rich people who
can't have a baby would you take four
million dollars to be caught on To Catch
a Predator no
who's saying yes to that
you're not going you're getting [__]
in prison every day let's say it's like
you didn't you you get you get sent away
for like messaging you never actually
did anything so it is it's not that long
it was dead how much if it's not 4
million how much would you need nope
what if it was a like a um how about
this okay you were
uh you're falsely
accused of this and you can prove like
no no like this wasn't me but everyone
sees of the episode and they still think
nope what about a billion dollars and
you and you're right you have the proof
you're like no no it was it was actually
a billion dollars if you do the if you
Google it I think for Adrian Apple Lucci
it's not me Dylan now 10 billion I've
lived poor my whole life I'm fine with
it all the more reason you should get
that money man I can't I can't I'd
rather kill a kid if you made that
abundantly four million to kill again
sure
not yesterday thank you for watching
answer the internet please subscribe to
the channel comment below on other
celebrities you'd like to see and make
sure you hit the Bell to get
notifications when new episodes come out